again I'd like to express my
appreciation for the invitation to be
here I am honored to have this
opportunity to share a word with you and
I pray that you would pray with me as we
reflect on the theme celebrating god's
grace and mercy amid tough times last
Sunday I had the awesome privilege of
attending a unique presentation by the
renowned Harlem visual arts and social
activist faith Ringgold she was
presenting at the New York metropolitan
museum of art and as she highlighted her
role in designing the 911 p story quilt
which was completed in collaboration
with a number of New York children who
had been traumatized like much of
America by the terrorist attacks of
September 11 2001 I hung on her every
word it was in response to this tribe
these tragic events that the
interrelations collaborative spear hated
head spill head spearheaded by a grace
yone gathered together children who were
ages 11 through 19 from diverse
backgrounds nationalities and religious
traditions and created a safe space for
them to share their experiences of 911
from their words and images they
authored also with the support of
Ringgold the insightful book which
inspired the quilt titled what will you
do for peace impact of 911 on New York
City you moved by the sincerity of the
children's work ringgold writes in the
introduction of the book when I was
shown the layout for a new book titled
what will you do for peace my heart was
filled with joy what a beautiful
collaboration
perfect response from New York's young
people this gracefully poetic account of
that frightening day and their young
lives is a gift of sensitivity and love
I was amazed at their generosity of
spirit I found the paintings and
expressive verse in the book deeply
inspiring as I scurried away from
Ringgold's presentation with my
colleagues and friends to view the 911
peace story quilt which was also on
display in the museum I was steadily
suddenly struck by the realization that
regardless of who we are it doesn't
matter how old we are what nationality
we are whether we're rich or poor
educated or illiterate at some point in
our lives we will all experience tough
times some may experience a personal
tragedy as they mourn the loss of a
loved one others will receive
heartbreaking news about a debilitating
illness and many in our country are
experiencing financial troubles brought
on by a waning economy and joblessness
and nearly a month ago families in our
own state of Connecticut experienced
utter devastation as they lost their
homes their businesses and everything
they owned due to the impact of
hurricane or tropical storm irene
unfortunately for the piece quilt
artists tough times entered their lives
at a very young age and turned it upside
down we were glued to the TV one child
wrote when we heard a plane crashed into
the Pentagon we started to cry I will
never forget my mom's face it will live
like thorns
in my heart when I turned on the TV
another wrote all I see was news on
every channel I was praying for the
people who died I thought about them and
fill another observed the day of sep
tember 11th was one of the worst days of
my life it made me feel sad for all of
the families who lost a dad mom and
uncle grandmother any family member I
just never actually suspected that
anything like this could happen yes some
of us will encounter bird was so great
that we may often wonder if we will ever
make it through in Psalm 145 David
offers us a ray of hope by shifting our
attention from our burdens to a litany
of God's Beauty Majesty and wondrous
works he reminds us that we serve a
great god a god who was able to do far
more than we can ever think or dream or
even imagine God is gracious and
merciful compassionate and loving and no
matter how hopeless a situation seems we
can trust in God's ability to bring us
through the most difficult times in our
lives in a similar fashion when Jonah
preached to the people of Nineveh it
seemed that there was no hope the city
would be destroyed because of their
wicked ways but when the people turn
from their sin God changed God's mind
and decided instead to save the city the
people of Nineveh experienced firsthand
not only God's grace and mercy but God's
power to turn a dire situation around
and then Jesus our Savior was on the
brink of
utter destruction he was mocked beaten
and crucified on the cross he was buried
in a borrowed tomb and after his death
it seemed that all was lost but early
Sunday morning he rose from the dead
conquering life's ultimate devastation
so when Christ we have hope for a better
day in Christ we have the power to
overcome life life's most difficult
situations and in Christ we have the
gift of eternal life like so many people
my journey has not always been easy but
i'm learning to celebrate god's grace
and mercy amid tough times but how you
may ask can we celebrate god's grace and
mercy amid tough times i believe that we
can begin by looking for glimpses of
god's grace and mercy wherever we go
when we are feeling low look for God's
grace and mercy in a golden sunset in
the laughter of children playing in our
community service or in an engaging
classroom dialogue we can also celebrate
God's grace and mercy by sharing acts of
kindness with others whatever we do does
it have to be big a simple touch a warm
embrace a heartfelt smile will do we can
further celebrate God's grace and mercy
by becoming instruments of God's love
compassion peace and justice and
ultimately we can celebrate God's grace
and mercy by reaching out to those in
need and becoming the answer to prayer
and someone's life in recent days the
911 artists
have become a symbol for me of
celebrating god's grace and mercy amid
tough times for even though they were
surrounded by tremendous violence
destruction and despair after the terror
attacks the young New Yorkers came
together from different cultures and
religions across New York City and
transformed their disastrous and
divisive experiences of 911 into a
healing uplifting and inspiring project
for peace thus their vision for peace
and hope inspires us to not only
proclaim God's goodness but to embody
God's love and God's peace compassion
and justice in our world as we gather
around the communion table this Sunday
let us celebrate God's grace and mercy
and a world that is enveloped by
tremendous sorrow and pain as we
celebrate communion let us remember
those in the midst of a severe famine in
Kenya and those families that are still
trying to piece together their worlds
from the devastating earthquakes in
haiti and japan let us remember people
all over the world battling the hiv/aids
pandemic and let us remember all who are
impacted by the wars in Afghanistan and
Iraq and most of all let us not forget
those among us in our own communities
who are suffering daily as we gather
this morning as a community of faith let
us also celebrate the hope that is
within us the hope of the psalmist who
proclaims to a people living in utter
destruction and despair that God is
gracious and merciful slow to anger
and abounding in steadfast love the hope
of the children who find glimpses of
God's grace and mercy as they strive for
peace and the hope in a risen Savior who
reminds us this communion sunday that
because he lives we can celebrate God's
grace and mercy amid tough times